[Music]
arrogance
makes you blind against the ones closest
[Music]
then
[Applause]
hi i'm stella chung from ign and welcome
to spotlight
the first in the ea series that connects
you to the games you love and the people
who make them
leading up to ea play live on july 22nd
ea invited me to come chat with the
developers who are defining the future
of first person shooters
so please join me in welcoming vince
zampella founder of respawn and group
general manager
chad grenier game director for apex
legends christian grass
general manager of ripplefx studios and
joining us live from dye's headquarters
oscar gabrielson general manager of dice
today we're going to talk about
first-person
shooters especially apex legends and the
recently announced
battlefield 2042 so let's jump in this
is an insane group
so doing some quick calculation how many
years of game dev
experience do we have here we've got
almost 20 years for just
all of it with vince actually yeah oh
i'm sorry are
those happy years it's been a roller
coaster
okay uh so i've been with
dyes for 20 years as well but with vin's
only for two years
so uh two good years though really good
years
i like that you specify that they're two
very good years
uh oscar how about you i'd say 24 years
uh you know kicked off early with
molding community back in the counter
strike and quake days uh since then came
into dice
you know north of 10 years ago so it's
been a thrilling ride of many different
shooters across the years
and this is the first time you guys were
talking i think we all individually talk
all the time but just as one group
we haven't all been together so this is
kind of
this is a very powerful group then
i guess it's like a powerhouse of mps
the apex games where the champions
are crowned but the arenas
are where legends are made so apex
legends took the world by storm
launching just over
two years ago and you had no
advertisement before
so do you guys have any stories that you
can share with us well
i recently just wrote a blog um on our
two year anniversary kind of talking
about how we kept the gaming secret and
did the
the beyonce drop um at the time like so
we kind of we kind of copied her
strategy there
always go with beyonce yeah then you win
flawless exactly
you revealed battlefield 2042 to the
world last month
how does it feel to have the news
finally out there uh well i i think the
theory is when you when you build a game
and you're kind of looking forward to
announcing it you're supposed to feel
excited and pumped and thrilled and all
those kind of positive words
yeah the honest reality is pure agony uh
the last couple of weeks before you show
off a thing
you know you have teams that spend years
and years and years hundreds and
hundreds of game creators creating these
games and then you get this final moment
where you get to show the game to the
world and you never know what reactions
is going to be but of course super happy
to be able to show the game to the world
it's something we're super pumped about
um so tell us about the game
and it's trademark game events that are
truly next level
you know not many times in your career
do you get the chance to go through a
console
transition so when we got the chance now
to work on the new generation of
consoles
it really enabled us to rethink some of
the kind of core building blocks of
battlefield delivering a game at a scale
we've never done before and it comes
both on the land masses you play
battlefield on but also the player
counts you know getting the chance to
play with 128 players
on an army scale kind of warfare setup
we added a lot of really cool gear to
the game things like
grappling hooks wingsuit and then for
some really cool reason we like to say
like what about a real-time tornado
real-time tornadoes are cool right what
about adding one of those to battlefield
and then what happens if you take that
and you combine it with a wingsuit so
you can kind of propel
yourself to the other side of the map
you know these tornadoes they
kind of helping kind of ground way when
you play uh there's been more than a few
play tests in which you're in this
really intense situation where you're
honestly pretty screwed
and then a lovely tornado shows up and
just sweeps all the enemies in front of
you like hey
that worked high five mr tornado uh and
i think those kind of
really big revolution moments that we're
introducing as part of balve 2042 is
what makes the game special
you need to play on your toes every
single second because you never know
what mother nature throws at you
can you shoot like into and out of the
tornado
of course you can shoot without a
tornado
one good way of understanding that the
storm's actually approaching is just
kind of looking up at the trees if
there's trying this you're starting to
bend a bit too much
you probably are supposed to start
running because you're gonna get you
know sweeped up for that tornado sooner
or later
can you tell me how long the team has
been working on the game yeah so this is
a three-year cycle for us and that
really has enabled us to both take a big
leap when it comes to tech so we're
running on a completely new version of
frostbite which has enabled us to push
both
visual fidelity and you know core
gameplay as a result
and really to kind of hone in on the
concept you've seen us talk about our
notepad specialists our new characters
and we've invested a lot of time and
kind of love and passion into the story
lines and the worlds and you know the
the war we're portraying uh so we're
super happy to get the chance to do that
so dice and dice la have had a long
history with battlefield
but before we talk about the history
dice la just rebranded
so can you tell us all about that
christian uh yeah so the studio was
formed eight years ago as a way of
expanding the capabilities that that
dyes had to build battlefield
we wanted to push this idea that we have
in the studio where we really want to
drive
quality and everything we do as a studio
and in order for us to do that in a
really good way we believe that you need
to be good at listening you need to
listen to the people that work
in the studio to kind of find these good
ideas these kind of
nuggets of good ideas that we then try
to turn into something real
and that sort of is ripple effect for us
it's this idea that great things have
small beginnings and that's kind of what
a ripple effect
is but uh we're super excited about the
name we feel like it represents us
it flows well it's a good name uh so the
work that oscar
and christian have been doing for
battlefield hasn't even been revealed
yet but christian i'm hoping that you
can maybe give us a little bit of a hint
uh so i can't say that much about it
uh what i can say is this though is that
one of the components in this experience
that we're creating
is that we're adding some of the fan
favorite maps
back into battlefield 2042 but the
entire experience you have to wait a bit
longer before we
reveal what that is
the team at dice announced hazard zone
at the reveal but
didn't say much we know it's being
developed at dice can you tell us a
little more about that
yeah i mean so battlefield 2042 ships
with three core multiplayer experiences
we've shown off all our warfare
of course christian and his team has
something special coming shortly that
will show at ea play live
and our second experience is called
hazard zone it's a high stakes
squad based game mode with a lot of high
tension it's not your classic
bel royale it's a really contemporary
mode it's also something the team has
been thinking about for many years i'm
really looking forward to showing it to
the world it has some really special
components and it really kind of leans
into the super powers of battlefield and
dice at the same time
so we'll show more later this fall just
a couple of weeks and months before we
launch the game in october so vince
you've been part of some of the biggest
fps games in the history of the genre
like medal of honor allied assault call
of duty and call of duty modern warfare
also the sequels to both of those
franchises titanfall 1 and 2
my personal favorites and apex legends
just to name a few
what is the secret ingredient to making
a great fps
a great team that was immediate
i love that yeah i think it goes back to
something christian uh
mentioned which is finding nuggets of of
gold
within the team members themselves and
and um
putting them into the game right
building a great team where people are
you know have this initiative and
they're passionate about making games
ideas come from anyone and so if you put
the right people in place then
those ideas just sort of happen is
assuming you have a collaborative
culture and a place where people feel
like they can speak up and pitch ideas
and not all ideas are good like you have
to be like we'll throw out ideas and
you know i'll say something and chad go
say that's stupid we're not doing that
okay and he's probably right most of the
time
what was the idea in apex that you guys
threw out
besides titan because we all know
everyone's been asking about titans
there's a lot
coming off of titanfall 2 we had a lot
of the titanfall 2 mechanics in the game
like the titans and that was something
that we
we decided to cut as well as wall
running and the jump packs
and i know those are all favorites of
titanfall players but they
added to what we call brownian motion in
our game where players can sort of be
anywhere at any time
and we wanted a slower paced more
predictable
combat where you know you can predict
when someone goes around the corner like
you know the
possibilities where they could be and
not and not that they can be anywhere
um and then the titans just sort of you
know were a weird balance they were sort
of
how do you make them powerful enough
that you feel really cool when you're in
a titan but
not op we had drop pods at the beginning
instead of jumping out of the plane and
sort of doing
the skydive we had a map that you would
pick where you would drop and sort of
just
instantly dart down in a drop pod but
you know we found during play test that
giving players more time to reposition
and see where other players are going
and rethink strategy
was more fun i'm going to check it out
over there it's a lot of play testing
and you know trying things and failing
fast and moving on or improving
if you see a promise in it so yeah i
think it's incredible to see like
your team work together and like you
said a great team makes a great fps
because now you have this title that is
esports ready
and you know algs has been doing wonders
a lot of people have been wanting to
enter into it and so it's just kind of
the proof is in the pudding right
yeah we're really glad that people are
playing it competitively and algs has
been great
just held the championships so that was
really cool um really big prize pool so
that's been exciting looking forward to
doing it again next year
i know you mentioned your team with
ripple effect now
so would that kind of be your same
answer yeah of course key is a great
team i mean that's how you succeed
the other thing that i really like is
and i think that's something that the
battlefield franchise has done well is
not being afraid of taking risks and not
saying no
instantly so if someone come up with an
idea like
having a tornado real time in the game
someone doesn't just say that's insane
cut
instead it's like yeah maybe that could
work and that kind of what if
question i think is super important so
you take some risk like we introduced
destruction back in battlefield by
company one into the game
which wasn't necessarily from a
development point of view a sane
idea but it was a cool idea and we
wanted it so we kind of pushed for it
even though
uh it was really difficult to do but
then like
like vin said you have to balance that
with the being
bold enough to cut things that don't
work as well and that is actually more
difficult than it sounds
it's difficult to cut things that you've
been working on for a long time so i
think that balance is really important
to strike
uh then turning to oscar is there
anything that you've had to cut from
previous games that you've worked on
that
kind of made you feel a little bit sad i
have one that i miss you know every
single day we'll hopefully get it back
in you know some battlefield version
it's actually something we did back in
the battlefield four days called tablet
commander
uh so you might remember you could
actually join into a 64 player
battlefield session on your tablet
either an android one or an ios one
and we even had voice over ip support so
you could kind of call in
supplies you know do a bunch of things
from the ipad and the reason i
remembered so well it was actually the
same year i got my first kid
so i couldn't sit in front of a console
or pc but what i could do is i could
carry my kid on one arm and i could have
my ipad another one i could scream at my
squad
and give them squad orders so we just
need to get tablet commander back and us
not having it in the next couple of
games is still really frustrating me so
we have to fix that
do you think we can make that happen
hopefully at some point it will be back
in the game i don't know though let's do
a classic christian you you and i this
weekend oscar let's
write some code yes how hard can it be
yeah i love the commander feature as
well that's a good call-out oscar
so going back to apex chad and vince you
guys have been able to knock it out of
the park with
every season launch and i think season 9
was one of the best because
you also brought back titanfall 2's most
infamous pilot
viper with valkyrie and created this new
backstory for a character that we really
didn't get that much screen time with
how do you guys keep doing it well our
writing team
just loves titanfall and they're trying
it you know every moment to try to
squeeze something in we've seen that the
fans really love it too
and so when there's an opportunity we
obviously want to do it the team is just
generally very familiar with all the
characters and the universe and
and all the lore so sometimes it's a
natural fit and sometimes we just you
know
we'll pull in a ash to to run the the
arenas or something like that you know
it's all in the same universe so it
happens
fairly naturally i think i saw that you
guys even pulled in
a community member to the writing team
right
i think that's incredible what was your
decision-making process on that
yeah as the game gets bigger and we've
got you know more
devs working on the game we needed to
really document and start cataloging you
know our lore and what we've done what
we haven't done and who's who
and so he had already been essentially
doing that for free
and so we just reached out and asked if
you want to work for us and uh yeah now
he works at respawn and he's sort of our
lore expert now
oh my god that's amazing yeah i mean the
universe is something that we're
building on and we have big plans for in
the future so it's really important that
we keep
keep our heads straight on everything
because it's not always easy
yeah and i i noticed that you also
brought in um i think
community artists for all the apex
panels and even on twitter
not even just in game so how do you find
these people
these artists and who how do you pick
them man
they there's been so much good art we
don't ask for it they just they just
post it and it's amazing thank you all
it blows our minds so we've done a bunch
of things with the community and
honestly we're just getting started
we're gonna you know hopefully do a lot
more we've um reached out to a few
people and they've done some comics for
some of our seasons
um we just partnered with someone in the
community to do an animated
pathfinder video game over
thanks for playing and yeah just getting
started there's so many amazing artists
out there and
you know we're we're also hiring so they
can always oh they can always apply also
but they're doing great work
that's amazing yeah yeah
i think that's amazing that you've been
able to tie the community into this and
kind of give back in that sort of form
i love it so much even the casual comics
that i see retweeted on
the apex legends twitter account i think
it's really cool that you've been able
to bridge that gap between people who
are
so passionate and aren't necessarily
developers or
in the gaming industry but they just
want to share their love of the game and
you
guys have like embraced the community
which is incredible yeah and we've been
partnering with them to actually
help get them actual lore so they can
release their own comics and things
that are that are actually you know like
a legit backstory and it's not just
their own creation but
yeah i think that's awesome some legends
fight for fortune
others answers but we shall all be
forged
in the glorious realm mirage quiet what
was the inspiration for apex legends
well we were really passionate about
making a team-based game
and we initially were prototyping with
different classes and how do you create
team play
and so some of our early legends were
like lifeline you know being the combat
medic
pathfinder came over from titanfall 2
and sort of
naturally found some abilities that was
fun
but i think once we honed in on making
the game about
the actual legends not so much the
abilities or the or the gameplay but
more through the eyes of these legends
that's when the game really took off
from a development point of view
and and a lot of the team just got
really passionate about the
actual legends themselves and who they
are and then things start
lining up and making sense like why is
bloodhound doing these abilities and i
think that's when the team sort of
became aligned and started working
together
victory yeah and i think we were looking
at what was happening kind of as we
progressed after titanfall 2 like where
we would take multiplayer and
kind of looking at you know the battle
royale space and it kind of blowing up
and we wanted to take that and do
something new and unique with it
so kind of combining that you know the
character base play with that just made
sense
yeah and i think you guys said that you
want to expand beyond battle royale
which was
evident in season nine's arenas can you
guys give us a hint at what else you
might be planning
going beyond battle royale yeah so
battle royale will continue to be a
primary focus for us
that's you know that's the roots of the
game but we have been trying to expand
beyond battle royale because we have
you know what we think is a really great
combat loop and a fun core gameplay um
and so we're trying to offer more ways
to play so we just released arenas in
season nine
and in season 10 i can confirm that
we'll be releasing a ranked version of
arenas
the rules are simple whoever survives
wins so i'm very curious what fps
defined you as a developer
so for me it's the first fps game i
shipped which was battlefield 1942.
it took off became a huge success to
kind of everything there on that journey
building that game and experiencing the
launch
i mean it's one of the greatest i guess
memories i have in
my career so that's that's the game that
defined me i just realized
you launched with 1942 and now it's
2042 how do you feel about that i feel
really good about it so when uh
i love the the name um so i think that
was a great
uh choice uh going back to to our roots
in a way so i really
i love that name and i love it sort of
coming together
uh what about you oscar yeah i have to
go back to my classic
counter-strike days i know i spent
decades and decades it feels like in the
game i still like on a rainy sunday
um instead of actually playing like
proper multiplayer games i will just
join an
empty dust2 server and i will work on my
smoke grenades just to make sure
i don't know why i haven't given up in
that you know given up on that dream of
becoming a pro player it'll never happen
uh but it's still my go to game on a
rainy sunday
and what about vince i'm very curious
um probably like doom because the
modding you know we
spent a lot of time like making mods and
trolling our friends as we played you
know kind of
lan party style um and then playing
probably
quake three arena was probably like the
game that i had the most fun you know
playing competitively do you think you
could have gone pro in it oh no
chad how about you yeah i'm kind of
surrounded by my idols here because
i grew up as far as multiplayer gaming
um playing a lot of battlefield 1942
and then what got me my start in my
career is actually
playing and modding medal of honor
allied assault which is a game vince
made so um and then you know that's how
i met vince and got my job and all that
and started working on call of duty
how does it feel like hearing all this
right now uh
it feels very good of course yeah it's
great but i mean it's like
we're all fans of each other's work i
mean i love playing a lot of salt
modern warfare was amazing i i used to
play a ton of um
counter-strike as well i think maybe
most of us did that was
that was a ton of fun so when are you
and oscar going to team up for cs go
that's a good question i'm pretty sure
oscar is way better than than i am so
i don't know or maybe you can carry me
oscar yeah i think the five of us you
know on this call were all great in
theory at least and that's a really good
start the question is if we can
translate it in a good place but maybe
maybe we could schedule something for
this weekend we just need to finish
these games we're working on
i think people assume that we're good at
the games like it's this weird thing
where you you put out a game
and instantly you have like an hour
window maybe where you
you know you know the tricks better than
the players and then they just surpass
you like that now
it's it's crazy actually i'm really
curious how many times like what what is
a moment where
you've seen a fan post gameplay of
something that you never thought was
possible in a game
every day every day is there like a
favorite moment what was the curved
bullet thing in titanfall
curved bullets i don't remember that one
yeah they used the warp thing and they
would curve bullets and hit people
oh yeah yeah i'm so glad i wasn't
playing against them yeah anytime we
release something new
also we think it's like really well
balanced and then we release it
and we just like oh no people are doing
that with it
um it's awesome love it okay what about
a battlefield moment because i know that
can get i mean you're adding a tornado
now
so what is what is one of the wildest
battlefield moments that you've ever had
uh i remember actually which was kind of
bizarre we were playing against a bunch
of journalists on bf 1942
early on and they took the b-17 and
started wing walking on the b17 so the
entire team
flew on the b17 walking on the wings
that was an amazing moment that like
yeah we didn't even know that you could
do yeah i mean
i think one of the kind of magic pieces
when it comes to battlefields notion
like what people can
do in a social construct and i mean and
many are actually the easter eggs we
produce across the years about it really
are all about players coming together
and doing things together to unlock
something unexpected or crazy
so there's some magic source there in
battlefield that really works well with
the community
so earlier this year ea moved need for
speed to go all in on battlefield
can you tell us how that works with a
total of three studios and ea gothenburg
supporting specifically on frostbite
engine tech
yeah i mean i'd say on a normal year it
would be borderline impossible
to pull in that many studios to build a
game like this but i think
this coveted environment that we've been
in means that it's actually easier to
scale teams because we're all in the
same kind of infrastructure zoom
meetings virtual whiteboards virtual
platforms you know everything has
the word virtual ahead of it so this is
by far the biggest battlefield team you
know we've ever had and that's really
enables us now to ship these like three
core
you know multiplayer experiences in part
to the battlefield 2042 launch
but it's been a grand adventure a couple
of months left uh you know and you see
kudos to everyone in gothenburg
guilford la and of course the team back
in stockholm you know everyone's come
together
and it's obviously not only those folks
there's been
engineers and artists and audio
designers from
kind of every single corner of the world
across electronic arts helping out on
this game and i think you've you've seen
it when you
uh you've seen the reveal trailer and
the gameplay assets it's really shining
through so yeah kudos and thanks for all
the help
things are about to get mighty
interesting so
chad we're coming up on the next season
of apex already
what are some lessons you've learned
from the past year
yeah there's been a lot of lessons i
think from uh from a development
perspective you know make sure that
we're we're giving everything enough
time to to be good before it comes out
i mentioned earlier ranked arenas coming
next season that's one of those things
that just wasn't quite ready and so we
just pushed it a season
i think early on we were probably trying
to hold our to our guns and release
things on
schedule and now i think we just we're a
little bit more flexible with that sort
of thing and i think the players have
responded well to that
um you know we'd much rather release
something when it's really good
and ready than to just get it done on
time yeah i don't think everyone
realizes how much time some of this
takes like
characters are we've gotten it down now
to only about a year
yeah it's a little bit more yeah a year
and a half or so so
like we spent a lot of time kind of
honing them so it sucks to rush it out
at the end
you know with things we want to be able
to have the time to to make it perfect
or as perfect as we can
out of curiosity how long would a map
take to develop
we're generally about a year and a half
from when we first start doing
blockouts to to shipping
what about map changes actually is that
any easier than doing full maps
updates it's definitely a lot easier um
like a map update
is generally about six months so we're a
couple seasons ahead on those
and then a town takeover we're usually
about one season ahead so and actually
i'm very curious how long does it take
to make a map in battlefield
somewhere between six and twelve months
based on size complexity is it a new
biome new gameplay opportunities it's a
bunch of time uh to pull that off
especially our big player counts it's
just a massive challenge
really balancing everything there so
then that kind of begs the question
how hard is it to run a live service
game
a lot harder than we thought
we're still learning how to do it i
think you know it's kind of we get
better every time i hope
and uh there's a lot of content a lot
you know it's a lot of
testing you know the good part of it is
you can put things out there and try
things and not being afraid of things
failing
you know but that puts a lot more bonus
on the team to create content
that the fans you know like they need to
last an entire three-month season
and have enough content to keep people
coming back and engaged and entertained
you'll see yeah we look forward to it
yeah i was gonna say is there any advice
that you'd want to give
christian and his team i'll let chad
answer this one
i you know if i could go back i think
the only advice i'd give myself was to
make sure
that you've got the the pipeline and the
tools and the
and the team ready to start creating
that content because for us
we were all in on launch we launched the
game and then it's like
oh this game got popular we have to do
like a season
season one what are we going to put in
it and we had very little content
ready to go yeah the first couple
seasons were yeah
a lot of work for the team yeah we've
slowed it down now and kind of
balance you know we want quality of life
for the team too so we kind of
always try to ride that line but the
first couple world
we were also just very used to two year
long or more light uh
development time and then a big release
and it was the same for the release of
apex so we had never done how do you
ship something in
in a month or in three months even so we
just had to completely change the way
that we think about development so oscar
i'm curious after hearing all these
stories
how are you guys preparing for
battlefield 2042's live service
you know of course we've had the
battlefield 4 live service we did
together with christian and the team
over in dice la
we'd had you know battlefield 5 just
recently we took star wars battlefront 2
on quite a journey adding new content
and updates involving that game a whole
lot after launch
so we have a couple of tricks up our
sleeve as we get to the
live service for battlefield 2842 and
many of those learnings actually
came from apex legends and all the great
work the respawn team has done with that
game
yeah i mean with this job you kind of
get to learn new things every day we
constantly grow and change and push the
boundaries so
it's one of the most exciting things
about doing this yeah
you also feel like when you release a
game that you work on for that long and
you're done
every you know my experience the team
kind of feels like they wish they could
have done this or that
it's never quite done right sort of the
artist mentality so the nice thing with
live service it's like well it's not
done you can keep
doing you can keep changing you can keep
polishing or doing whatever you want so
there's a benefit you also get that
instant kind of gratification so
normally we spend two to three years
before anyone sees what we're doing uh
whereas in a live service world we can
create something today and then a few
weeks later it's in the hands of players
when we were doing the community test
environment for bf4
that loop was even shorter we did
something on monday and it was in the
hands of players on tuesday because it
didn't have to be perfect it was a test
environment
and our developers love that that
instant feedback they get from something
kind of working that closely with the
community it's very different from the
quiet and secret
uh secretive for two years and then we
launch it
seems like you guys have a lot of fun
with it which is really great this is my
favorite part
exciting it's time we jump to the part
that everyone has been waiting for
what does the future of fps games look
like to you vince because you have the
most history with fps games we'll start
with you what does the future look like
apex versus battlefield love it
deathmatch we're going to bring it on
um i don't know i think the you know the
best part is we don't really know yet
there's so many things that we
haven't even thought about or put
thought into yet that that it's exciting
and
we get new consoles now so we see the
you know the power that we haven't even
really started to unlock yet so that'll
get better and better
yeah how about you chad um the other
thing that excites me
is there's a whole new generation of
gamers and we're up here talking about
you know games we've played in the past
and there's people who have never even
heard of them or never have the chance
to experience them
so i think there's a lot of gameplay
experiences that you can pay homage to
or something or experiences you can
you can bring right um respawn just just
made a world war two game
for instance and i grew up on a world
war ii game that vince made ironically
um and i think a lot of people
experienced it for the first time and
learned something about world war ii
and um so just opportunities like that
there's a whole new generation of gamers
and
so that's exciting question it feels
like there's so much more we
could do and and should do on the kind
of social side of our games
if you look at a traditional sport you
could kind of i know you could go
outside and just kick a ball or throw a
ball
and you can watch it on tv and you can
go to a stadium and watch it
and you can participate in fantasy
versions of it and it's like it becomes
more than just that actual game
which i feel like we're only at the
beginning of that where we can turn it
into more of a social thing where you
you know you hang out in this world in
these worlds that we create not just to
compete
but also just to be there with your your
your friends i think there's a ton
of ton of exciting potential there yeah
oscar i'm very curious as to what your
answer is you know cloud computing has
really changed a bunch of other
industries and
game is kind of barely touched on it so
if you think about a game like
battlefield we have things like ai in
the game now destruction
actually procedural level creation and
the next-gen consoles there are
of course super powerful but if we move
much of that logic out to the cloud
which is kind of servers and other
language we can do some really high
scale computing that we haven't been
able to do
in the past destruction visual fidelity
uh and i think it's
just a couple of years away and then
you'll see some pretty cool shooter
games out there i'd imagine but we'll
see
soon trademark battlefield 2042 being
one of them
no comments oh okay
so chad what should we expect from ea
play live on july 22nd
yeah so our next season is rapidly
approaching so we're going to be
unveiling some new information around
our upcoming season
including uh some information about our
next legend
he is very interesting and unique in
many ways
and i think players will be really
excited to learn about him
i'm very excited to learn and i'm
assuming you can't hear more
about that but i'm so excited so oscar
what's your fans expect
from battlefield 2042 at ea play live on
july 22nd
so i think it's that mode that was on
the whiteboard for many decades and many
years and never kind of happened and now
christian's team and they have been
you know orchestrating and building it
so christian yeah i mean
it's it's super exciting and of course a
bit nerve-wracking kind of showing
something
for the first time but uh hoping that
the
the players the community will uh will
really embrace and like what we're going
to show them on
uh july 22nd yeah i think they will
christian that's cool
it's really exciting it's cool it's
really cool it is the passion from the
team comes through so you know
every time they show it off it's it's
amazing yeah chris and his team actually
showed
lars mr battlefield gustavson uh that
experience just a few weeks ago
uh and you know lars as you might know
has been with the franchise for the two
decades that existed i think it was
jumping around
on the zoom chair really really happy
with what we saw and i think that's a
great testament to what to expect
in at the year play live so get a sturdy
chair ready to watch it
well thank you guys so much for joining
us here thank you for having me
it was so great to hear everyone's
experiences and i'll let you guys get
back to your game development i'm so
excited to see what you guys have in
store for us
so thank you for joining thank you thank
you thank you thank you for joining us
for this first spotlight
more from the ea play live spotlight
series coming soon
follow at ea on twitter or go to ea.com
for the latest updates
also remember ea play live is july 22nd
and you don't want to miss that
i'm stella chung from ign and this was a
ton of fun
thanks everyone for joining and i'll see
you on the battlefield
you